[Music]
on September 6 1520 to the Victoria
sailed into harbour in southern Spain
the battered vessel and its 18 sailors
were all that remains of a fleet that
had departed three years before yet her
voyage was considered a success for the
Victoria had achieved something
unprecedented the first circumnavigation
of the globe but this story really
begins in 1494 two years after
Columbus's voyage on behalf of spain
Columbus's discovery had prompted the
catholic spanish rulers to turn to the
pope to preempt any claims by portugal
to the new lands the pope resolved this
dispute by drawing an imaginary line on
the world map
Spain had the right to claim territories
west of the divide and Portugal to the
east Spain and Portugal
the two major seafaring superpowers at
the time agreed to these terms in what
came to be called the Treaty of
Tordesillas
at the time these nations had their eyes
on the same prize trade routes to the
Spice Islands in today's Indonesia the
spices found there which were used as
seasonings food preservatives and
aphrodisiacs were worth many times their
weight in gold but because of Portugal's
control over eastern sea routes Spain's
only viable option was to sail west so
when a Portuguese defector named
Ferdinand Magellan claimed that a
westward route to the Spice Islands
existed King Charles made him captain of
a Spanish Armada and gave him all the
resources he would need along with a
share in the voyages profits he granted
Magellan five ships and about 260 men
the crew included a young slave named
Enrique captured by Magellan on a
previous journey to Malacca and Antonio
Pigafetta a Venetian nobleman seeking
adventure on September 28 1519 the fleet
weighed anchor and headed southwest
after making landfall in what is now
Brazil it proceeded along the coast
exploring any waterway leading inland
they were looking for the fabled passage
linking east and west as the weather
worsened substandards resentment at
having a Portuguese captain escalated a
full-blown mutiny soon erupted which
Magellan crushed with unspeakable
cruelty but his problems were only just
beginning during a reconnaissance
mission the Santiago was wrecked by a
storm then while exploring a narrow
waterway the captain of the san antonio
took the first opportunity to slip away
and sail back home
Magellan pressed forward and on October
21st
he started exploring a navigable Seaway
twenty-seven freezing days later the
three remaining ships emerged from what
we now call the Strait of Magellan into
the marpa cific oh the fleet never
expected the new ocean to be so vast
after 98 days at sea
dozens of sailors had succumbed to
scurvy and famine when they finally
reached land again and regain the young
slave proved able to communicate with
the natives their gold couldn't be far
sailing further west Magellan was warmly
received by Rajah Humabon of Cebu so
when the ruler asked him to help subdue
and convert the rebellious chief of
Mactan the captain readily agreed the
adventure would be his last
overconfident and severely outnumbered
Magellan's force was overwhelmed and the
natives bamboo spears and did the
captain's life yet the voyage had to
continue Magellan's will specified that
Henriques should be freed but the
expedition still needed an interpreter
with his freedom at stake and rege a is
believed to have plotted with the Rajah
to have about thirty of the Spaniards
killed at a feast on the beach and rek
was never heard from again
but if he ever made it back to Malacca
he may have been the first person to
actually circumnavigate the globe
meanwhile the survivors burned the
concepción and proceeded onward they
finally reached the
spice islands in November of 1521 and
loaded up on precious cargo but they
still had to return to Spain the
Trinidad sank shortly after being
captured by the Portuguese the Victoria
continued west piloted by one Sebastian
Elcano one of the pardoned mutineers
against all odds the small vessel made
it back to Spain with a full cargo of
cloves and cinnamon enough to cover the
expedition and turn a profit an
obsessive chronicler Pigafetta described
the lands and people they encountered
with the help of a humble slave he also
compiled the world's first phrase book
of native languages his journal is the
reason we can tell this story Magellan's
legacy lingers he had galaxies and space
programs named after him Elcano too was
celebrated in Spain with a coat of arms
and his face on currency and stamps
united by fate the survivors and the
hundreds who sacrificed their lives
challenged conventional wisdom and
completed a historic journey once
thought impossible
you
[Music]